i like listening to people speak russian
you ever heard people speak russian
it's amazing they just sound like
they're talking backwards the whole time
[Applause]
vladimir
i've discovered the secret to the welsh
accent isn't so much a phrase it's more
a state of mind
to do a good welsh accent you've just
got a sound confused whose coat is that
jacket
i just want to know uh how many latinos
in the crowd tonight
now notice i asked latinos i wasn't very
specific
because if you call a latino the wrong
one there's an issue you call a mexican
a salvadorian we get mad
you call a puerto rican a dominican they
get mad you call a cuban anything but a
cuban you're gonna get stabbed
[Applause]
[Music]
so for everyone here and everyone at
home i have found a way
to figure out who's who it's very easy
all you have to do is listen to the way
the person is speaking spanish
you don't have to understand a single
word just listen to the flow that'll let
you know
for example mexicans when we speak
spanish we sound high
seriously you ask us a question we drag
it out hey bro how's it going
[Applause]
know cubans i found out cubans you guys
speak spanish like
everything means something it's very
serious you ask a cuban a question bro
where you going
just asking dude it's like why is he
yelling i don't know
and i found a puerto ricans you guys
speak spanish like there's a time limit
ask a question hey bro what's up
[Applause]
even mexicans were like hey write that
down
it's funny when i say asian especially
in america when i say asian
people automatically picture in their
heads
[Music]
which is messed up because india is part
of asia and we don't get the same credit
when i say asian people don't go do do
we're asian too man when god was making
asians he made two types of asians
and you guys got first choice on looks
and you [__] us on the deal
we'll take eyes
you guys can have noses and hair
my people are greedy we're here too too
we got two that's good dear too
noses and hair we didn't know it was
gonna be big noses and body hair that's
a [__]
deal
[Applause]
we're a hairy race of people man it's
hot
as hell in india and we're hairy
who the hell came up with that deal i
think the god that was making indian
people was having some sort of practical
joke with all the other gods
he's like hey guys guys come here to
watch this watch this
[Applause]
okay look i'm going to take these people
here
and put them in the hottest place in the
world
and just for fun
i'll cover them with hair
it's hot and we're hairy men and women
indian girls getting mad pulling down
their sleeves i hate this son of a [__]
[Applause]
everybody listening to drake my mom
listens to drake but look at all the
different
genres of music drake delves into right
could do r b
do rappy dude [__] the chat hate [__]
he do goddamn
afro beats you know what i'm saying
yeah you sound like champagne mcgregor
[__]
all right how do i get how do i get more
how do i get more jamaican with it
i don't know i always resort to the
gichi accent you know you saying
like from charleston you know i bought
in charleston so it's kind of like
no i know gully and pathway different
ain't the same
yeah that's way different yeah they
ain't the same it's nice yeah yeah
no no jamaican jamaican
jamaican you sound like golden crust bro
what's up
i think it's the most disrespectful [__]
in the world don't you fix your mouth to
talk about the beef party
you being here don't you fix your mother
talk about me yo shout out to everybody
oxtail institute peace
everybody inside everybody a t-neck in
jersey and a weird snapple
it's this stripping t-neck where you got
like it's not a real snapple but it kind
of tastes like snappa tropical fantasy
we call it listen you got the
antique you ever been a teenager you've
been a teenage new jersey right i've
been to t-neck
i've been to t-ball remember where i
used to live yes
jewish people no no no
no no no jews
no jews
twisty things kind of like the dreadlock
y'all
[Music]
look he's late every single day he's got
to be jamaican
he got 15 jobs he's got to be jamaican
his name is dwayne
[Music]
that's how he said because jamaica's
people
no they're not they're actually some
happy people no why you think we smoke
so much marijuana they're too happy
we need that yo you're going in and out
of like four-leaf clothing bro
like you're going back and forth between
[__] curry and full leaf clover
my name is donovan mcintyre
put some jerk sauce on that potato put
it on it
we want a guinness and a red stripe mix
together
we're not playing with y'all
[Music]
um i am here in boston i'm gonna get
ready to do the [__] cam nearly
dennis leary um
benefit on saturday at the boston garden
the td north bank garden whatever the
[__] they call it how about your boston
bruins they're just on a tear
even though they uh lost a close one to
the hated habs
that's good for the frenchies up there
right they get to cry into their little
[__] pocket squared hankies
um i haven't you know i've moved away
from here so goddamn long ago that like
i am having difficulty a few times
understanding the boston accent
just really upsetting to me because this
is where i'm from
i actually i did a couple of shows at
laff boston
um out on the pier it used to be where
anthony's pf4 was
way out there you know drive out to this
great italian restaurant it was like one
of the greatest italian restaurants
in the country and uh but you kind of
took your life in your hands going out
there because it was uh was
kind of shady out there out there on the
wharf
um but now it's all built up out there
like everything's all built up now
so i went down there um this was city
thursday i went down there tuesday night
do a quick 15-minute set and uh
the club owner says to me he goes hey
bill jubal over here
and i was like what juba over here
i had to like process it oh he's saying
did you uber
over here juba over here
uh yes i ubered over here uh
jubal over here hey bill
hey burp you [__] uber over here
you [__] uber over here um yes i did
i did uber over here
so uh that kind of surprised me
it's the first time in a long time uh i
think ever that i haven't been able to
understand i think it's because uber
has happened since i left so i haven't
heard
uber i always knew uh jeet no jew
that was did you eat no did you i
remember my vocab improvement
uh teacher in high school you that's how
you started cheat
no jew saying how we need to learn to
pronounce our
our words more so i knew that jew
was did you you know
most places it's the beginning of
something anti-semitic but here that
is did you jew uber
over here juba over here
um i learned a new one that's why y'all
are always on when animals attack
you will never see black people or when
animals attack
you might see us on when cops attack but
she will never see us
on an animal's attack y'all would do
[__] like tranquilize a lion and hold
that [__] tail he'd wake up
and that'd be heavy [__] to y'all y'all
be in the camera
[Music]
well my partner bob and i
we've been tracking this particular
beast for quite some time
her name is utulu she's six months old
we just shot her with five cc's of tetra
coeur d'alene darts
when she gets up she's gonna be [__]
pissed
oh my god bob do you feel your heart
pounding this is amazing
oh my god she's getting a plow oh she
molded me what an experience
the africans don't be out there [__]
with the lions they ask them mr matumbu
why you don't play with the lion
i'm not [__] with that [__]
[__] him and [__] you
that [__] is not in the brochure i'm not
doing that [__]
when my shift is over i want to go home
to my children mangulu mangala and
i can't do it [__] with that when the
[__] you're out you better come i will
leave you in the car
it's rules
ain't no african people here is it are
you african dog my bad
i want to piss you off and you
[__]
you know what's [__] up african people
don't like black people
y'all know they treat us like [__] they
talk down to us they think they're
better than us
and i don't understand because we're
from the same tribe
kind of but they like white people
though they treat y'all like family
as soon as y'all come around they get
excited excuse me mr white man
thank you for bringing us here we love
you
yay the white mommy
as soon as they see us they get an
attitude hey how you doing this
[__] we don't like the black man in
america [__] you don't work you
don't do [__]
we don't like you you black [__]
like oh you calling black [__]
i'm brown you midnight who the [__] are
you calling black
like [__] if you stood up against the
building you look like an alley who the
[__] are you
the [__] is unjust